we are often taught that the best way to
prove attractive is to smile the idea
feels logical and for the most part
highly appropriate but it shouldn't
blind us to the occasional claims of a
contrary minority approach this one
founded on an awareness that friendship
between people is ultimately based not
on booster ich accounts of recent
triumphs but on the possibility of
shared grief sadness and melancholy this
may explain the surprisingly intense
charm of attractive people who are
resolutely not smiling but instead look
lost in thought absorbed by their own
sorrows and taken up with an internal
dialogue around pain and loss they may
well pull a smile if asked but it will
be obviously rather strained and brief
like a moment of sunshine between dark
grey clouds they are beautiful not
despite their sadness but however
curious this sounds precisely because of
it in the Western artistic tradition the
most prominent sad beautiful person was
for many centuries the mother of Jesus
in many representations Mary was elegant
serene and poised but she was also quite
obviously sunk in sorrow and concern but
the sadness did not detract from her
appeal rather it made the viewer feel in
the presence of someone who would be in
a position to understand their own
sorrows someone around whom it would not
be necessary to put up a front in the
name of seeming normal our longing for
love is at heart powered by a desire to
be understood and to understand given
how much of life is tragic in structure
it follows that for many of us the sort
of people we feel ready us to love are
not going to be those who find the
business of living obvious or easy but
those who are as puzzled and saddened by
it as we are those who feel a regular
need to withdraw from the sentimental
bonhomie of day
those who are alive to anxiety and
catastrophe and who may like us
frequently feel close to tears it's so
much that it's regretful and sad
we have been keen to pathologize and
medicalize expressions of unhappiness
and our ideals of physical beauty have
kept pace with our prejudices our
billboards and movies loudly proclaim
the virtues of glowing contentment but
we are in danger of missing out on one
of the richest sources of beauty which
is when our faces drop their usual masks
and visually acknowledge the pain of
existence a moment of honesty and
vulnerability on the basis of which true
friendship and love can arise we love
bringing you these films if you want to
help us to keep bringing you thoughtful
content please consider supporting us by
visiting our shop at the link on your
screen now
you